the other person who is at great risk
of of a lawsuit related to all of these
bogus uh election claims
is the man himself
donald trump
been talking about the dominion lawsuit
and it looks like uh donald trump is not
going to possibly remain unscathed from
the the multi-billion dollar set of
lawsuits that have gone out
uh the insider's reporting that dominion
lawyer says the voting technology
company is still exploring whether to
sue trump over election
lies
dominion voting systems is still
weighing whether to bring a defamation
lawsuit against former president donald
trump over election conspiracy theories
an attorney for the company said tuesday
dominion continues to take an
evidence-based approach to investigating
other participants in the campaign of
lies dating all the way back to last
november attorney stephen shackleford
told insider at a press conference
the election technology company filed
three lawsuits tuesday morning against
the right wing organizations one america
news and newsmax it has also sued two
employees of oan as well as former
overstock ceo
patrick byrne
well let me tell you it seems as though
something donald trump will be very keen
on
if you remember his support of
opening up our libel laws whatever that
means so we can sue journalists and make
a lot of money remember this moment
and one of the things i'm going to do
and this is only going to make it
tougher for me and i've never said this
before
but one of the things i'm going to do if
i win and i hope i do and we're
certainly leaving
is i'm going to open up our libel laws
so when they write purposely negative
and horrible and false articles
we can sue them and win lots of money
we're going to open up those libel
laws so that when the new york times
writes a hit piece which is a total
disgrace or when the washington post
which is there for other reasons writes
a hit piece we can sue them and win
money instead of having no chance of
winning because they're totally
protected you see
with me they're not protected because
i'm not like other people but i'm not
taking money i'm not taking their money
so we're going to open up those libel
laws folks and we're going to have
people sue you like you never got sued
before
and make
a lot
of money because again
that's the that's the mission of donald
trump that's the mo that's the impetus
for donald trump's existence is to make
a lot of money
and to create general chaos in his wake
it wasn't just on the campaign trail in
2016 though that he said these things
even when he was actually president of
the united states sitting in the white
house
he was committed to
violating the united states
constitutional uh the first amendment
and our right to free speech that the
government shall make no law
abridging the free press
uh remember this moment on a separate
front we are going to take a strong look
at our
country's libel laws so that when
somebody says something that is false
and defamatory
about someone that person will have
meaningful
recourse in our courts
if somebody says something that's
totally false and knowingly false
that the person that has been abused
defamed libel will have meaningful
recourse
our current libel laws are a sham
and a disgrace and do not represent
american values
or american fairness so we're going to
take a strong look at that
we want fairness
you can't say things that are false
knowingly false
and
be able to
smile as money pours into your bank
account
we're going to take a very very strong
look at that
and i think uh what the american people
want to see is fairness
so again donald trump wants to take a
strong
look at our libel laws
because you know by his own account you
can't say things that are knowingly
false you just can't do it
it would be a beautiful
poetic irony poetic justice if donald
trump was to fall under foot to be sued
for hundreds of millions of dollars
depleting any money that he actually
does have
over this
after all of the bluster after all of
the nonsense about opening up the loyal
laws
if he was to fall prey to a defamation
suit where he was found guilty
and have to pay damages
because let me tell you
dominion ain't playing around
and donald trump is at risk
here and he is justifiably at risk
because he has damaged our union
in an attempt to over overturn an
election in an attempt to overthrow the
very government
under which we live
through his insurrection
his his whipping up of his his followers
into a frenzy where they wanted to
assassinate the vice president of the
united states
they erected the the hangman's gallow on
the lawn of the capital
all of these image that should stick in
your mind because it is reprehensible
behavior and if in some way
there could be some justice justice
meted out via lawsuit even a civil one
that would be good
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100 percent of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 percent off and free shipping when
you go to four sigmatic dot com slash
pacman the link is right underneath this
video